c'est un avertissement sévère qui
survient avant une rencontre cruciale
entre les etats-unis et la russie
l'union européenne et les états membres
ont une position de force commune les
états unis les aînés de l'otan aussi son
ensemble et nous disons très clairement
il y aura des conséquences considérables
et un prix à payer très important si la
russie dépôt une action militaire en
ukraine
une ferme démonstration d'unité pour
tenter de dissuader moscou d'envahir
l'ukraine ces derniers mois la russie a
massé des dizaines de milliers de
soldats à sa frontière ukrainienne
moscou dément toute intention
belliqueuse mais continuent d'utiliser
la menace militaire comme moyen de
pression diplomatique pour stopper
l'élargissement de l'otan vers ses
frontières
poutine ne peut pas accepter que
l'ukraine ni la géorgie d'ailleurs
rejoignent l'otan il a décidé de tenir
bon jusqu'au bout sur l'ukraine est le
seul moyen d'assurer son autorité
politique forte sur ce pays c'est de
créer des tensions à la frontière
en cas d'invasion washington promet de
couper moscou des rouages de la finance
mondiale ou d'empêcher l'entrée en
fonction du gazoduc nord stream 2 qui
relie la russie à l'allemagne et doit
acheminer du gaz russe vers l'europe
mais moscou exclu toute concession
le risque d'une confrontation n'est donc
pas exclue selon le secrétaire d'état
américain
huit ans après l'annexion de la crimée
et malgré plusieurs accords de cessez le
feu le bruit des armes n'a jamais
vraiment cessé à l'est de l'ukraine